hello everyone and welcome to our
incredible match
the 1858 match between yohanyako
bloomintel and paul charles murphy
uh this is game 14 uh i believe this is
game 14 let me just
check one more time as it might not be
uh but i'm pretty sure it is no it's uh
it's game 13 and
we've seen game 12 it was really crazy
uh but this game features uh like the
title suggests one of the
worst moves ever played in chess history
and i know the competition is steep uh
there's uh well
just by missing mate in one we have
evancho
uh vasily vanchuk versus anand we have
uh
uh karp of barre we have kramnik missing
mate in one against deep fritz so
the competition is fierce but those were
all games
uh played in extreme pressure or not not
just time wise
extreme time pressure and the games were
extremely
important so here this is a game without
a clock
and you know you can take as much as you
want for a move like
uh okay you can't take forever because
it's gonna be rude but other than that
you're not breaking any rules so i
definitely think this game
uh deserves to be uh among those games
if not above them but you'll see what i
mean by this so
uh let's check it out uh lentil with the
white pieces uh tries to get back into
the match
he plays e4 with e5 by morphe knight f3
knight to f6 and now knight captures on
e5 so
a normal pattern of defense nothing out
of the ordinary here the classical
variation
d6 kicking back the knight knight f3 and
knight captures on e4 now we have d4 and
d5 this is still a standard theory uh
even today in 2020 with bishop to d3 and
bishop to e7 both players prepare to
castle
uh we have castles and now knight to c6
and of course c4 putting pressure on d5
uh and here
this is up until this point uh even
though the game was played in 1858
this is still top uh top theory played
in 2020 approved by
deep fritz approved by uh lee leches
zero approved by pretty much
pretty much everyone uh and here today
we would see a knights to b4 this is the
go-to move uh however in those days
bishop to e6 was the was the idea just
add a defender here
so here we have c captures on the five
by elemental morphe recaptures and
knight to c3 he goes after the bishop uh
knight captures on c3b captures and here
morphy just castles and here we have
bishop to f4
and he was uh uh at this position from
move 12 that
this position has never been reached
again so let's
let's see what happens here uh we have
bishop to d6 morphe offers a trade uh
and
uh low until obliges we have captures
captures morphy gets a free
uh developing move for his queen uh and
knight
the g5 already threatening upon here on
h7 so morphy has to decide how to deal
with this either either he will play h6
or
f5 f5 being more aggressive uh morphy of
course
chooses the the latter option so here we
have c4
pushing the bishop back and here morphy
doesn't like
retreating with the bishop because well
it's just not pleasant if you go here
you
you're just going to face a double
attack on the bishop end on the knight
and if you go all the way here then the
rook no longer guards the f5 bomb you
can just pick it up so here
morphe plays the only good move and that
is bishop captures on g2
so a temporary piece sacrifice because
you're gonna pin the knight and
win the piece back that's not a problem
so king captures on g2
and the queen to g6 now morphy says okay
now my pawn is nicely defended i don't
mind d5 the knight will come into the
game
and i'm gonna win back my piece uh after
playing h6 so here we have
f4 defending for the moment and h6
as planned uh we have d5 going after the
knight and here
uh well you could go knights to d4 and
you probably should uh morphy decides to
go back with knights to d8 he
probably has some plans of going to the
f7
and then maybe to d6 and then from there
to e4 and and who knows what
however we have h for bilomental now
with
a double defensive uh pawn move on the
knight and here morphy recaptures the
knight we have calculus captures
and only now knight to f7 so here uh the
pawn is pinned so morphe is actually
planning knight to h6 and then to g4
but there's a problem here we have queen
to f3 by lomento
and now knight to h6 of course the
knight cannot be captured but
uh problem is uh luintel just ignores
him with queen to g3
and now the problem is you cannot
continue with your plan because
just queen captures here and after
characters the queen on g6 is
undefended so here morphe retreats back
with the knight as now
of course the pawn is no longer pinned
you can simply capture it so knight back
to f7
and now c5 preparing to to push those
pawns to create a pass pawn of course
you still need moves like rook to d1
bishop c4 and then d6
but uh logan tell has something very
very nicely planned out
for morphe so rook 8 d8 now threatening
to win the d-pawn
and bishop the c for defending now of
course any c6 ideas or something like
that will be met with d6
however morphe finds the very
interesting b5 saying
okay uh you either capture and then i
can finally capture on d5 you can also
capture up a song
uh well i'm just gonna recapture uh with
with either pawns it's gonna be fine
uh however we have bishop back to b3
just keeping the pressure
defending the pawn and at some point
white will be ready to play some like
rook to d1 d6 and so on
so here we have a5 planning a4 so the
bishop will have to move and
while white can counter this with a4
here we have
rook 8 to e1 an incredible move
by uh by lovingthal uh
trying to create another immortal game
against morphy it would seem because if
you continue with a4
now uh rook to e6 just wins the game for
white because if you move the queen
this is just winning and of course if
you go uh let's say h5 with the queen
then just bishop d1 and
the queen is lost of course you can go
back to h8 but then rook h1
and that's it the game's over so
after this rook 8 to e1 morphy needs to
figure out what to do here so first
rook f2 e8 he wants to counter one of
the rooks to get his king some breeding
square
as you know this is coming and you do
not want your king on the light square
however there's the problem rook the e6
once again and here here
the problem is that whatever you do
doesn't really work
that because morphe after he captures on
e6 and it's a must
otherwise you're going to lose the queen
we have d captures now the pawn is
protected and you cannot move the knight
because
well all the knights all the squares the
knight can go to are taken
except h8 but even that doesn't matter
because if you move the knight it's
check uh the rook will fall and
you don't even have to capture the rook
it's actually a beautiful
checkmating idea king h7 queen h3 check
and even after queen h6 you don't
capture the queen but rather you play
this with
check and now it doesn't matter now
everything wins for example
simplest uh simplest way to show you
queen g6 rook h1 is checkmate so
nothing to do here the bishop still
covers the g8 square the queen is pinned
so you cannot block with the queen
and the rook of course delivers
checkmate so after this d
captures on e6 move uh morphy is forced
to
waste a move uh by playing king to f8
and getting his king to a dark square
so here uh johann yaakov uh says
okay thank you for the knight e captures
on f7 uh there were other moves
you don't have to rush anything but uh
he he decides to grab the piece and
as well you should i mean it's a free
piece uh we have
a4 and now another beautiful move uh not
moving the bishop but rather rook to d1
forcing a trade here so rook captures on
d1
bishop captures and now queen to c6
check
uh now morphe is down uh down a piece
but at least he will
uh grab the c5 pawn and maybe he can
create some sort of a pawn storm here on
the queen side so here bishop to f3
blocking
and now queen captures on c5 but now g6
and now you have this uh uh amazing pawn
uh structure here with the past f7 pawn
it so if you allow something like queen
h4 followed by queen h8 to check it's
it's going to be over you can queen the
pawn you can check the king
that's just it so here uh here you're
basically resigned there's no point in
continuing this game
uh however that we wouldn't have we we
probably wouldn't uh
uh i don't know we'd probably show it if
morphy resigned here
but we might not have but uh i mean
what happens here is just uh crazy
so here queen to d6 uh morphy says uh
all right i'm gonna reposition my queen
maybe i can start pushing the pawns here
it all depends basically on what white
does so here
queen to g5 now if the queen moves let's
say you move the queen to a
weird square not that but let's say you
do something like this then it's just
queen to d8
mate in one so morphe has to be very
careful here and he goes queen to d2
with
check with king to h3 and now queen to
d3
again guarding the the mating square and
also threatening queen captures on f3
with
check so here queen to h5 guarding the
bishop and also threatening just queen
to h.a to check and then you can bring
another queen into the game
and so on so here morphe says okay king
the e7 now it's still a problem you
still can't
go queen h8 because now it comes without
check and i'm just going to grab your
bishop
so queen h4 check and now king to d7
morphe starts shifting his king all the
way to the queen side
king to g3 now the bishop is defended
and now once again
you are free to queen the pawn because
you don't have to worry about queen
captures on f3
with check so here queen to d6 morphy
guards the queening square
and uh well now it's white to move uh
feel free to pause the video and
win this game for white uh while i give
you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on playing
any move any move whatsoever that
doesn't blunder the g6 pawn with
check which means you can play anything
you can play king h3
and then this is nothing because you get
another queen into the game
uh you can defend the pawn you can play
king h3 king h2 you can defend it with
queen h7
really just anything works here works
here other than
giving up the pawn with check and this
is exactly what luventhal
does here he plays queen to h8 and it
makes sense you're threatening to bring
another queen into the game
also queen to e8 is the threat of
instant checkmate as the king and uh
queen and pawn prevent the king from
escaping
however he allows queen captures on g6
and this is what i meant
uh there are a lot of games uh you know
that we can say oh no this is the
greatest blender ever this is the
the worst move ever played but those are
all basically modern games uh yes
amongst
uh extremely strong players but they
were using the clock so
there was always the time pressure
there's i mean
uh the pressure was much higher uh but
here it's without a clock you have all
the time in the world you you can
like win the game any way possible you
play a move like queen h8
and morphy says all right thank you for
the pawn queen captures and g6 this
comes with
check so you will not be enjoying any uh
any extra queens we have queen back to
f2
and now queen captures an f7 and all of
a sudden the position is
very very unclear it's uh uh bishop and
two pawns against
five pawns morphy and well you've just
ruined your game i'm pretty sure you're
not feeling all that all that great so
here
morphy's next plan is to play b4 and b3
create a pass pawn and win the game so
of course a3 is played
preventing b4 and it's a it's a pawn on
a dark square
uh so you the light square bishop will
not be able
uh be able to defend it however it is
the way to go and
trying something like b4 right away uh
for example a
captures and a3 is is
possible but um not
uh not not quite uh not quite working as
white will be able to defend it uh
because you can always hide the king
behind the bishop and
well the queen can easily easily reach
the pawn
from from either side of the board so
it's not it's not gonna be a
that big of a deal so that that being
said
let's see what actually happened in the
game after a3 we have queen to e7 by
morphe
he went for the pawn this way he wants
to
grab even more material however it's
very difficult to actually do it because
you will hang the g7 pawn so here we
have king to g3
and now comes queen to e1 with check
like i said if you go for queen captures
on a3 then queen captures and g7 comes
with the check
and yes you have three pass pawns here
but
the bishop and queen will do uh will do
a sufficient job at keeping the black
king at bay
so after king to g3 we have queen to e1
checked by morphe
king to g2 and now queen to d2 with
check
king g3 and morpheu repeats queen to e1
with
check and it was in this position on mu
44 that
the game ended in a draw and
this unbelievable unbelievable game
happened where this
uh i don't know i don't know what to say
about this where this queen to h8 move
was played like here
congratulations to everyone who played
any move other than blundering the pawn
with check but here queen h8 is like
the absolute nightmare the the absolute
worst move you can play giving up this
this is a
this is not just a trump card this is
like this is everything
like that beautiful g and f pawn so
uh at first i thought uh you know i as
we don't show all of the games in the
morphe saga
i actually thought about skipping this
one and i already skipped it but then i
was like
no but let's let's at least check it out
i mean it could be some sort of a hidden
gem and it's a good thing i did because
i would not know about this game and how
well
how low intel just ruined a brilliant
game he played against morphy
so and it's not uh not the only one and
definitely not the first one so here
morphy advances uh well he
prolongs his lead it's now 10 to 3 in
the match
and we will show at least one more game
from the match and then we continue
further into the morphe saga as stronger
opponents are coming
so what do you think about the game what
do you think about this move uh
is it like the worst move ever played
because uh
i really think it's amongst the the top
three there
especially because this play this game
this entire match was played without the
clock uh but i don't know
i like like i said the competition is
steep uh so
uh that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank marco van
kempen uh petrovich younger selling
khanov
uh david chest look and anthony greg for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my uh previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day